hey guys just seeing here with a new
episode of log university welcome now
take your seats if you're already stated
fantastic now I know most of you have
probably been really busy at real school
and in case you haven't had a lot of
time to sit around and watch pointless
videos on the internet like I have
here's a few of my favorite that I
watched this week let me know which
one's your favorite this guy right here
has real potential he's got great music
he's got great moves yeah should we try
it again nope maybe one more time no
there's nothing that I love more than
watching someone continually fail while
attempting something and inflicting pain
upon themselves did I just admit that
yes I did it is true but what makes this
video so freaking perfect is that most
parents are super supportive of their
kids and their ambitions and their hopes
and their dreams but nope oh not this
mom oh stop you are not gonna be the
great breakdancer you think you are it's
not gonna work her ankles okay and this
is totally swollen thanks mom I'm gonna
go take my swollen ankles and go play in
traffic I hope there's a big white fans
handing your board ah
somebody just give this kid some britney
spears already seriously mp3 a CV I
don't even care I don't think she cares
as long as she hear some Britney Spears
thank you thank you thank you now that's
a sign of true parenting right there
some of you probably aren't aware of one
of my favorite games used to be unreal
tournament so when I came across this
mod to use 999 in an nyan cat as a
weapon I about lost my sheets of paper
so beautiful hope you guys enjoyed some
of my favorite videos from this past
week not just like every other vlog
university episode I give you guys
homework assignments this homework
assignment is actually to make a video
of you guys making a homework assignment
so from now on I'll use one of the
videos that you guys create for this
episode for future episodes of homework
assignments for other people to complete
they can be anything from a video
challenge jus well pretty much anything
all you got to do is add it as a video
response to this video and you might
find yourself in a future episode of log
University in the last vlog University I
had you guys complete a drawing that I
had started on start at me now you guys
submitted so many amazing drawings that
I can't actually feature all of them but
i will put a link in the description so
that you can check out the thread and
see some of the drawings for yourself
anyway here's a few of my favorites
all right I'll see you guys soon thanks
for watching don't forget to subscribe
so you know when i launched new videos
and of course follow me on twitter and
facebook and google+ and all of that
crazy nonsense and i'll see you guys
when i see you rps i have some new
t-shirts out to link in the description
goodbye